first of all i'm brad i am one of the
co-founders at unstoppable domains
we build domains on blockchains so
domain registries which are
smart contracts on blockchains domains
are nfts
and i'm talking today about how
blockchain domains plus ipfs
uh gets you a decentralized website
uh so we build uh domain registries we
have two registries dot crypto
and dot zill we also have a registrar
like our version of godaddy uh
called unstoppabledomains.com
and we also have decentralized web tools
so
things like we have a demo browser which
is uh
open source fork of chromium we have
browser extensions we have a marketplace
of ipfs templates
ipvs deploy tools and libraries for
domain resolution
so why do we need a decentralized web
well the current dns system
is easily censored uh it relies
on registrars which are mandatory
custodians of domain names
like com domain names all traditional
domain names uh registries can revoke
domains or they can be taken down
and hosting services can take con can
take content completely
offline um not just off of their
platform
and so decentralized websites websites
are an alternative because
domains are nfts uh no custodian is
required you can store your domain
inside of your wallet so
crypto domains you store inside of an
ethereum wallet
blockchain domain registry is like
unstoppable domains and ens they can't
revoke your domain
uh and the hosting is on decentralized
storage networks like ibfs
instead of on uh centralized hosting
providers so that's why blockchain
domains
plus ipfs equal decentralized websites
uh so i thought i would just show
everybody the product real quick if
that's all right
so this is unstoppabledomains.com you
can search for a domain
this is basically how you would expect a
domain registrar to work
you can check out you can of course pay
in crypto
i just use a coinbase commerce widget
right now so these are the
uh these are the defaults hopefully we
can get filecoin in there too though
uh we've got credit card we've got
paypal
and once you bought a domain you claim
the domain to your wallet
and then you can manage and manage means
that you add crypto addresses
to your domain name so that you can
receive money you can
receive bitcoin eth litecoin you can
receive any cryptocurrency
uh and add ipfs hashes uh so that you
have websites so what you do is
you add an address you click save you
sign a message with your private key
a lot of people use metamask that writes
that information to the blockchain
and then application can look that back
up i'm just going to show you a gift
real quick
hopefully this is big enough for
everybody to see but if you type in
brad.crypto
into trust wallet then you can pay
you can pay me in ethereum bitcoin
whatever
um so it all works it also works inside
of
these wallets right now plus many many
more coming
okay so after i have added my crypto
addresses
i can then go and add my pfs hatch so
there's a few different things that you
can do here
one is you can just you know build your
website build your application
copy and paste your hash sign a message
with your private key write it to the
blockchain
but you can also upload files so this is
actually using
pinata in the background as a uploader
so shout out to pinata cloud
and we also have a template marketplace
for non-technical users and so this is
kind of like our little decentralized
wix here so you've got
a little image editor you can add text
whatever
uh this this is really bare bones right
now you're looking at like basically
profile pages you know we're like this
is like
1995 geocities level of the internet
type thing
uh but there's uh blog
uh templates coming soon there's
ecommerce store templates there's
a need for marketplaces forums a whole
bunch of different stuff
and we've got more than 20 000
users who have registered domain names
and they're looking for tools
so this is open we're looking for people
who
want to build like ipfs template tools
and offer them to our users whether paid
or unpaid depending on what you're
what you're focused on so
that's that so now if i want to go view
a website
so we have a unstoppable chrome
extension
we're also integrating with several
chrome extensions actually working on
ipfs companion right now working on
several others
um but you can just
type in and by the way can everybody
hear me and see my screen and everything
could yep just fine okay great
let's just start um all right so this is
my ether wallet.crypto so you've got a
essentially a fully functioning version
of my ether wallet
so i've got kyber.crypto where
you can do an eth die exchange these are
websites that are live right now
so we also have a demo browser
and the idea behind the demo browser is
that this is supposed to
inspire browsers to support ipfs
and other decentralized decentralized
storage networks
so there's an ipfs node inside of this
browser so when i go to
you can go to my silly little my silly
little ipfs website
i can run the node i can turn on the
node
and now when i go to the website
brad.crypto
i am storing and sharing into the
network too so this is like a method for
uh unincentivized sharing of ipfs files
and the motive would be i like this
website
and so you can imagine cases in the
future where somebody really wants to
put something out
and it's popular but being censored and
then you could just have a whole bunch
of
people who care about this news story
getting out or whatever
and they can all be storing and sharing
it and all you would need is to add
you know one click so this is uh open
source
uh the ui is terrible so if anybody
wants to fork it commercialize it
play with it do whatever you want please
please do
uh yeah so ways to view websites there's
the demo browser
uh there's extensions uh opera for
android
is live right now so there's 80 million
monthly unique
users who can type in a crypto domain
type in a dot ethe domain
they can view website sites that are on
ipfs
so it works right now hopefully coming
soon i'd be your best companion and then
we've got
uh many many more uh browser
relationships that we're working on
right now
and uh i would say just that just in
general i think that um
the decentralized web community has
turned up the heat and
browsers are paying attention in 2020 um
i think i see uh juan nodding there um
this is
not not true i would say in 2019 because
i was
you know trying to talk to them then as
well as much and
i think it was definitely not true in
2018 so i think things are actually
uh are actually heating up so there's a
bunch of stuff going on with
mozilla right now as well with some
projects they're looking at
so we're just we're seeing a lot of a
lot of action coming from a lot of
different places
uh so our stats we've had more than 200
000
domains registered so far there's more
than 4 000 ipfs websites that are
launched
yes honestly most of those are people
trying to resell their domains right now
but there's about there's about 2 000
that are not that
um that are people doing other things as
well and all of this
has happened uh essentially the past two
months since
the website tool started going live and
since the template tool start going live
so people are using and digging in
non-technical users are digging in when
when the tools are easy enough
so yeah more than twelve thousand unique
ethereum addresses with domains
uh and these users are looking for tools
to build ipfs websites more easily so
we've got
traffic coming to our site we've got
these users that are
looking for stuff to play with so we
would love to chat with anybody that
thinks that
their tool might be interesting to
people who are trying to launch websites
here are some companies that are
building stuff with us right now
some missing pieces
that we have identified which i'm sure
are on top of mine for a lot of folks
here
uh well decentralized database stuff so
we're looking very closely at what
textile orbit and uh and gun db are
working on
in order to solve some of these problems
and uh we also have this uh this paid
hosting problem
so one of the themes that we've seen
from
uh customers so far has been people who
are formerly
uh relying on youtube for their business
and they
have uh you know they've been especially
crypto content has been getting censored
on youtube and so
uh they're looking at the decentralized
web they kind of think it's not quite
ready but
uh they're looking and you know they'd
be doing video
video hosting so you know
incentivization to make sure that that
content works
and it works fast is super important so
um
we're really excited about filecoin and
we think there's
potentially a lot of demand here
especially if we can start getting uh
getting
video up because that's the stuff that's
expensive
so if you wanna if you wanna consume a
lot of file coin i think video customers
are a good place to look
um so that's one of the reasons why
we've been talking to a lot of crypto
youtubers
we actually have a need for a template
that would allow them to
easily launch their videos and maybe
charge for them
or launch their videos and do like a
monthly subscription
so that's an opportunity if anyone's
interested
so yeah um please uh please build with
us
um so i mentioned the templates um
there's also some dev and deploy tools
you know we're looking at
uh some stuff that uh that fleek is
doing the textiles doing a whole bunch
of other folks are doing
um so there's a lot of there's a lot of
cool deploy tools that are coming out
right now
um we would love to point that stuff
um you know the best stuff to to our
users to our technical users who are you
know who are looking for that
domain resolution in any of your
applications wallets browsers apps would
love to talk about that
uh also the browser there's um a link to
our github it's open source please
fork please do whatever and if you have
an app with users and you might want to
sell domains um talk to us as well
so yeah that's um that's it
and yeah let me uh
stop here and open up for questions and
sorry i haven't really been watching the
chat
that's awesome thank you so much brad
it looks like you're getting a question
from
thomas um unincentivized sharing um
as it relates to crypto crypto domains
yeah so the unincentivized sharing was a
reference
to the feature in the browser where
you turn on the ipfs node
and the reason why you do it is because
maybe the reason why you do it is
because you can't you know view the
website unless you
agree to do that that could be like one
way that somebody could implement it but
the way that we defaulted to in our
browser is
you go to a website you just have the
option the button is there and you can
just click
store and share the website and the idea
is that the reason you would do that is
because you
care about what the website's saying um
so that that's all
that's all i i really meant but i think
there's there's probably room in the
market for both ideas that you know you
have
you know your incentivized sharing for
your uptime and stuff like that but you
could also imagine some sort of
viral content or whatever that didn't
even need the incentive
um because people were just like you
know this is great or
maybe more realistically this is
offensive or something else like that
well i guess we don't really know what
the what the what's going to be the
viral moment for
um yeah for decentralized storage stuff
um and yes i'll uh i'll share the deck
i'm not sure where to do that but i'll
i'll do that can you stick it in the
chat or
tweet it at us or whatever okay cool
question from juan are there things you
need help with from pinning services in
terms of storage
backup opportunities to help drive
product success for you
yeah uh so pinning services
yes uh well i think that for us probably
the
biggest thing is going to be um
like uh trustless subscriptions
for hosting stuff you know so somebody
wanting to reliably buy like
one year of uptime so all the stuff to
make that happen
you know and you know this is
essentially like file coin plus
subscriptions
uh stuff so that's like a really big
area
i know we've uh chatted with the the
textile folks and it sounds like they're
uh working on some parts of that um
that's not something that we've been
working on directly so we're definitely
looking for help there so that's really
that's a really big area i would say the
other really big area
is uh the templates
so i know this is not necessarily the
place that everyone's mind goes first
um how do i get non-technical users to
launch websites
but i would say that one of the things
that
i one of the impressions i get when i
talk to a lot of tooling companies
is that their customer
theoretical customer many of their
theoretical customers
are other tooling companies who are also
equally competent and therefore don't
require quite so many tooling companies
yet because right now
the pool of developers is much more the
enthusiast category we're like everyone
knows what's going on
and so i think the the forgotten
opportunity here a little bit
is these non-technical users who can
crank out 4 000 websites
in six weeks and with just you know very
very simple
like our templates are terrible like
we're gonna we hope that
they're all tr they're all most of them
are in the trash
uh in a few months or at least modified
to be you know it's definitely not
anywhere near as good as what you would
get going through a godaddy experience
or something like that
um and there's all kinds of cool stuff
that you could do here like so we've got
you know there's like the marketplaces
stuff like
similar to what kind of like the origin
team has been working on so that's
you know a category uh blog with like a
paywall
is super obvious we're working on
versions of that but we would embrace
other people
um you know launching those as well and
again you can
what happens on our site is you buy a
domain and then you go what's next
i know it's supposed to do something
with ipfs what's next and there's a
large number of domains being
being bought to some extent by people
thinking that you know this is going to
be uh
you know a future you know important
registry but there's a lot of
people who are saying like i was around
for the 1990s 2000s phase i'm trying to
figure out what parking tools look like
here i'm trying to figure out
um how to i'm trying to figure out how
to be first
and i would launch 100 if i had the
right type of things you know so we're
seeing a lot of that stuff
um so long answer but i think the
templates are
the place where you would get the most
kind of immediate
uh immediate jolt from the dev tools may
be less so
totally hear you i definitely i tried
the experience of like
forestry to fleek to decentralized name
um and it worked surprisingly well so
you just grabbed one of like the hugo
default templates off of forestry i
think there's a number of those like
static site templates
it would be really cool to just like
like literally
glue those things together where you can
like one click
like it spins it up it puts it in your
github repo it connects it to fleeq
so that it's put up on ipfs and then it
updates your
your domain name like those little bits
of like glue tooling that make it super
seamless for everyone to get started
um i think we're pretty amazing and
would love to i feel like you guys are
already headed straight in that
direction with like templates built into
the um
the domain name registry and all those
things there
so maybe forestry is the next partner
there yeah would definitely
i definitely need to need to look closer
at forestry and i think that just
to to jump on that because i think
you're you're totally right that's the
goal
it requires a lot more stuff to be
connected in together and so
we're really focused on that uh right
now so we'd love to probably work with
everybody honestly
um in some way and i also think that
there's
um like a motivation whatever there's
maybe to challenge the decentralized web
community uh d5 already has this
and it's awesome like the
interconnectedness across all the
dapps with the web3 experiences being
consistent across all these apps
is amazing and it's way further ahead
than where the decentralized web is
right now in terms of ux
so i i kind of see that as like a
i don't know a little bit of inspiration
that like it does it does it's starting
to work
and i think we should be more like that
all of our stuff should very easily
stick together and be able to go in
these like packages
across all these apps and that should
that should be the vision so it's
basically like we just need to like
pack dozens of different tools all
together and then make it really easy
for everyone to
access it so yeah
modularity and composability i love it
that was super cool i i only was
recently digging into
all of the um all the d5 tools that have
put their
front ends up on ipfs a lot of which are
using um
unstoppable domains which is super cool
um and so it was really cool to dive
deeper into that space it's like oh wow
this is
super critical for truly having a
decentralized application with a smart
smart contract back end
yeah one that just came up i think it
was actually earlier today they found
they got it up which was um
a vulcan feed stock crypto i should have
put it in the thing which is
a chain link feed and so
it if you think about if you think about
long term
relying on some sort of decentralized
oracle system
you're then also going to need to make
sure that there's no reliance
on this web infrastructure that can just
be taken down otherwise
you're still going to wind up with your
data feed turned off at some point
so it's the dapps that it's the most
obvious for i guess
you know why if you ask like who's the
decentralized web customer that
absolutely needs to
needs it today i think it's the dapps
probably first
um because they're also on board to the
tooling and then probably next would be
like the
like the political distance like the um
like hk map live like the
that sort of stuff for the hong kong and
things like that
totally agree any other questions
for brett
yes yes there are more questions great
write them down
oh the anticipation
drum roll
would you put bounties on templates uh
yeah yeah we uh we have a bounty up i
i hope it's still up um we had a
thousand dollar bounty up previously
um but yeah we absolutely do um so
yeah i see juan going so yeah we'll
we'll definitely
uh publish some numbers and we'll also
i think make them bigger that's a good
idea
awesome i want to play roblox okay sorry
oh sorry i just i just noticed one other
one from
uh juan about about tooling that would
make our lives easier or maybe i
even addressed it partially but i just
realized there's also this other thing
which is
um it would be good to have good user
flows
for um for you know like deploy
stuff um and i know there's a lot to
that there's a lot of people that are
working on great stuff and part of the
problem then is is then like who do you
point to like where
you know how do you just point to
something simple that allows a developer
to figure it out so that's a
that's a problem and we don't really
unlike the templates we don't
the ui of that like how do you get it to
a developer is maybe a little less clear
so
question on topic uh so given moderation
being a problem how do you see the
moderation
question evolving in in the crypto
domains you have like i imagine
fairly quickly you people start once
once these
um these domains like really really work
that
you were saying um various groups that
have reasons to worry about censorship
are gonna start using uh
all of these domains uh how to see
moderation evolving through these things
or is it just kind of like a wild west
um or or uh do you imagine like that
there will be some some way of societies
moderating
um how names point going to uh
yeah totally um so we
have a philosophical view
that the base layer
should not have any censorship
or filtering or anything of any kind
basically the technology
should not decide what's okay and what's
not
because ultimately you'll then need to
rely on some person or some group of
people or some company or whatever
to do that filtering and then it will
just
be abused just like the regular system
is so it's basically like the only way
to have a secure system is to have tools
that take no opinion at the base layer
but then you have
the result of the world we live in will
be
browsers so like you know browsers are a
point
that may need to make decisions about
say like do i want to not show i mean
they're definitely going to want to not
show things that are so just so people
understand like the record
can be on the blockchain so i've got my
domain name i've got my ipfs hash on the
blockchain
domain name can't be taken away from me
nobody can update my record other than
me
but a browser can simply ignore decide
not to read that record
so what the effect will be in the real
world
is that you could have 99.99 of
uh browsers or other places that you're
allowing you to view websites saying
this is not okay
and then you might need to view some
open source
or extremist or whatever tool in order
to get access
and it could still be illegal uh just by
virtue of
accessing it could still be a crime in
the place that you live
so that can that'll still wind up being
for the things that are
super antisocial that'll still wind up
being in the dark depths of the internet
just like it is today
also not completely stopped but i think
that the
benefit that you get in this new
paradigm
is that you'll have multiple versions
of what's okay to say of free speech
right
now you have one version on the regular
web it's essentially whatever's
adjudicated by governments and whoever
pressuring the registries and the
registrars and
and uh web hosting companies versus a
future where you could have like
a on-chain filtered list
of or you know blocked a list of bad
domains and applications can read that
list and they can share
and they can decide okay well you know
i'm going to
out so i'm going to prove i'm going to
use this
smart contract which hopefully is you
know being adjudicated by an aclu or
something like that
and i'm going to say like they're going
to determine free speech and i'm going
to rely on them
and then if i decide that they're no
longer ethical i can
switch to another one or i can provide
filters in my browser for my users
where they can accept left-wing version
of where free speech
line is versus right-wing version versus
maybe even no-line whatsoever or you
choose the line and you could have
dozens of different versions of
of the internet that we all kind of
chaotically
move between if we want to um i think it
it's not that dissimilar from how the
current internet works or
how the current behavior of the internet
works already the difference is is that
all the power is sitting in the
individual users now
and you can't have you know companies
allowing movie producers to go and just
take people off
like right now you have all kinds of
weird ways that people manipulate the
current system so i'm not super worried
about it because i think that it's a
better world that way i think that we'll
get to
i think we'll have like really good
adjudicators
of free speech because that'll be a
business opportunity like somebody
actually
we actually need this service provider
to come in and be like
new blockchain focused aclu
and analyze and determine where the line
for free speech is and then the
facebooks and the youtubes and all these
other companies don't have to
they can just hit an endpoint and
get their you know answer on where the
line for free speech is
and they don't have to be the moral
arbiters anymore and that's a better
world